[Musica]
oggi si parla di sfide e una
dell'immagine più delle immagini più
comuni delle sfide nell'esplorazione è
quella di puntare sempre più in alto non
puntare alla vetta
per raggiungerla la mia sfida invece
quella di andare sempre più in basso
puntare al fondo non è detto che tutti i
sognatori debbano per forza avere gli
occhi al cielo ognuno può sognare quello
che vuole e io ho sempre sognato di
toccare il fondo il punto è che sono un
biologo marino è quello che mi intriga
di più vive nelle profondità del mare in
quelle zone ancora inesplorate laddove
gli occhi degli uomini non sono ancora
arrivati eppure c'è tantissima bellezza
da scoprire e quindi stasera voglio
accompagnarvi in un breve viaggio nelle
profondità del mare ma non vi mostrerò
posti esotici o luoghi lontani da
cartolina o da viaggio di nozze
anche perché con questo coronavirus
meglio restare in zona e quindi voglio
mostrarvi le profondità di casa nostra
farvi vedere le meraviglie nascoste del
nostro mare il mediterraneo mostrarvi
cosa c'è lì sotto in corrispondenza
dell'orizzonte quando uscirete da questo
castello e guarderete il mare ecco il
mare non è questa distesa azzurra è
deserta ma lì sotto pullula di vita
forse anche più dell'ambiente terrestre
e il nostro mediterraneo per quanto
piccolo rispetto agli altri mari è
ricchissimo di specie iconiche e
bizzarre davvero singolari è tra queste
tra le più belle secondo me ci sono loro
i coralli gli animali fiore noi zoologi
li chiamiamo antozoi dal greco anthos
cioè fiore animale proprio perché
sembrano quasi dei fiori ma in realtà
sono animali a tutti gli effetti e
quando si parla di coralli beh spesso si
pensa alle barriere coralline tropicali
in realtà anche in mediterraneo abbiamo
moltissime specie di coralli dalle forme
più diverse e dai colori più sgargianti
questi che vedete ad esempio sono stati
fotografati tutti nel canyon di bari un
canyon profondo circa mille metri
situato proprio di fronte la città di
bari che ospita una delle comunità di
coralli di profondità più interessanti
del mediterraneo e ce l'abbiamo proprio
in puglia bene alcuni di questi coralli
possono formare sono coralli duri
e quindi possono formare ecosistemi
simili alle barriere coralline
altri invece ecco sono arborescenti
sembrano quasi appunto degli alberi
questi che vedete possono superare il
metro di altezza vivere oltre i 2000
anni e hanno questo colore bianco e
sott'acqua sono bellissimi da vedere con
questo colore bianco quasi accecante
tant'è che si chiamano coralli neri ora
diciamo il mestiere del biologo non
sempre così intuitivo
in realtà si chiamano coralli neri
perché sebbene siano bianchi e il loro
scheletro ad essere nero nel nostro
gergo zoologico li chiamiamo anti patari
dal greco antipato scontro la sofferenza
perché in passato venivano utilizzati
questi scheletri così rari così belli
venivano utilizzati per confezionare
amuleti contro il malocchio le malattie
e la sofferenza appunto ovviamente non
funzionano come amuleti però sono molto
importanti per la sopravvivenza del
nostro mare proprio perché in opportune
condizioni molte colonie possono formare
delle vere e proprie foreste di corallo
e se ne conoscono pochissime di foresta
di corallo nero
tuttavia sono estremamente importanti
perché proprio come le foreste sulla
terra sono il posto in cui moltissimi
animali vanno a riprodursi a trovare
rifugio a trovare cibo o a deporre le
uova
quindi salvaguardare questi ambienti
vuol dire un po salvaguardare la vita
marina come la conosciamo oggi è la mia
sfida è proprio quella di trovare le
ultime foreste di corallo nero rimaste e
proteggerle prima che sia troppo tardi
e per fare questo mi sono recato alle
tremiti abbiamo fatto un progetto di
ricerca proprio alle tremiti io ammetto
subito di essere di parte perché sono
innamoratissimo delle isole tremiti e
secondo me sono uno dei posti più belli
mediterraneo e ce li abbiamo davvero qui
vicino bene uno dei gestori dei diving
center di un diving center alle tremiti
una volta mi portò un rametto di corallo
nero che aveva trovato durante le sue
immersioni e lo sapevano tutti che alle
tremiti non c'erano coralli neri però
allo stesso tempo i fondali profondi
delle isole tremiti quindi quelli oltre
i 50 metri di profondità che più o meno
il limite della subacquea classica erano
ancora inesplorati
quindi li ho capito subito la mia sfida
abbiamo messo su un team di ricerca con
l'università di bari e siamo andati a
cercare i coralli neri esplorare i
fondali profondi delle isole tremiti
lo facciamo con immersioni subacquee
anche fino ai 60 metri e più in
profondità utilizziamo dei robot si
chiamano rom sono fondamentalmente dei
veicoli filoguidati che io piloto
dall'imbarcazione che ci permettono di
osservare il fondale è questo tra
l'altro è stato raccontato in un
documentario prodotto da national
geographic questo stiamo mettendo il
nuovo e questo è quello che abbiamo
trovato le tremiti
niente ore ore giorni di esplorazione a
volte non trovi niente lady solo questa
marines no la neve marina che è la
sostanza organica che dalla superficie
arriva il fondo e tu continui a cercare
non ti arrendi sembra così stare in una
miscela spaziale continui continuerà
esplorare e alla fine vedrete ecco
queste sono le prime immagini dei
coralli neri delle isole tremiti le
prime immagine che abbiamo girato
immaginate la gioia eravamo i primi
esseri umani a vedere questo pezzo di
mondo nessuno prima di noi l'aveva mai
visto e noi abbiamo il privilegio di
mostrarlo agli altri di poterlo
raccontare ed era pieno di colonia
colonia grandissime bianche sembrava
quasi una foresta delle meraviglie ed è
una delle foreste di corallo nero
attualmente più grandi tra quelle che
conosciamo il mediterraneo ma perché
vogliamo conoscere questi ambienti
perché vogliamo sapere dove sono
chiaramente per proteggerli da cosa li
proteggiamo li proteggiamo da noi stessi
purtroppo nell'esplorazione di
profondità oltre a osservare la bellezza
e la biodiversità di queste oasi
sommerse ci troviamo a documentare gli
impatti che volontariamente o
involontariamente noi esseri umani
abbiamo su questi ambienti questi
ambienti sono pieni di immondizia gli
ambienti profondi sono il ricettacolo
dell'immondizia sono piene di attrezzi
da pesca abbandonati e ovviamente ci
sono gli effetti dannosi dei cambiamenti
che noi stessi stiamo apportando al
clima e al pianeta ad esempio è molto
comune trovare reti o palangari
abbandonati che si sono impigliati nei
coralli o nelle rocce quindi vengono
lasciati sul fondo questi rimangono lì
per sempre perché il nylon
è biodegradabile o addirittura troviamo
rifiuti di tutti i tipi e qui in auto a
lei in auto la vostra sinistra ho voluto
mettere una foto emblematica che ho
scattato durante il mio dottorato 420
metri di profondità
lì c'è un sacchetto dove c'è un sole che
sorride c'è una scritta verde sacchetto
biodegradabile che chiaramente non si
sta biodegrada nando e sta soffocando
una colonia di coralli che a occhio e
croce a 500 anni
per questo chi usa un sacchetto
biodegradabile non lo sa nemmeno che poi
ciò che biodegradabile sulla terra non è
detto che lo sia in acqua
ecco che quindi è chiaro che abbiamo
bisogno un attimino di rivedere il il
nostro modo di stare al mondo
e questo chiaramente comportano
sacrificio la sfida è sacrificio e
tenacia ma è anche rinunciano anzi io
direi che la sfida della nostra
generazione è proprio quella di
rinunciare il vero progresso non sta
nell'avere di più in un mondo
globalizzato né in un mondo di
consumismo ma sta nel chiedersi cosa
posso avere in meno di cosa posso fare a
meno e questo alla fine molto semplice
piccole azioni quotidiane possono
davvero fare la differenza
ridurre il consumo di carne evitare
l'utilizzo di plastica e monouso cercare
di ridurre l'utilizzo dell'automobile o
preferire il treno l'aereo ci sono c'è
una marea di cose che possiamo fare ma
non ve le devo dire io
nell'epoca in cui tutti abbiamo accesso
a internet essere ignoranti in queste
cose è una scelta
chiunque abbia uno smartphone in tasca
con una connessione a internet non può
dire non lo sapevo ci mettiamo cinque
minuti a informarci su questi argomenti
i nostri nonni magari potevano dirlo ma
noi non abbiamo scuse ed ecco che se noi
riusciremo davvero a ridurre la nostra
impronta sul sull'ambiente
sarà un ambiente stesso ripagarci io ne
sono certo il mare ripaga sempre
e a questo proposito voglio mostrarvi un
ultima cosa proprio quando stavo
cercando le foreste di corallo nero le
isole tremiti e non le trovavamo il
tempo passava i soldi finivano perché i
budget dei progetti ovviamente sono
limitati
non mi sono arreso continuando a
cercarli ho continuato a cercarli e alla
fine è e guardate cosa è successo ho
cominciato a vedere dei movimenti strani
né al bordo della telecamera del mio rom
quindi affermato le eliche e
all'improvviso un banco di riccione di
centinaia e centinaia di esemplari ha
cominciato a volte a volteggiar c
attorno un'ulteriore prova
dell'importanza di questi ambienti
perché queste foreste di corallo che io
cerco di proteggere sono delle vere e
proprie stazioni di servizio nel lungo
percorso che queste specie compiono nel
nostro mediterraneo e quindi vedete sono
queste che mi hanno dato la speranza ci
hanno fatto capire che eravamo sul
sentiero giusto che lì da qualche parte
ci dovevano davvero essere delle foreste
di corallo nero e quindi abbiamo
continuato abbiamo continuato alla fine
le abbiamo trovate e io con queste
meraviglie danzanti con queste riccio le
grandissime oltre un metro e lunghezza e
sono qui nel nostro mare io vi ringrazio
vi riporto in superficie spero che
davvero possiate vedere anche alle
nostre piccole azioni quotidiane in
maniera diversa e allo stretto rapporto
che la nostra vita di tutti i giorni ha
poi con l'ambiente profondo grazie
[Applauso]